so for people who are joining this
livestream this is an internal meeting
looking through functions that have been
experimental in previous versions of
Wolfram language which we are trying to
finish polishing and confirm can be made
non experimental to be a permanent
feature of the language going forward so
we are starting with something in
Geographics yeah actually this one is
easy I think geo image is in fine shape
yes I think so
the connection to the external providers
has worked well and we have a number of
users who requested extensions and
things then what kind of extensions well
Dave do you remember that we gave them
3,000 times per month for free oh yeah
right right right
I mean extensions of that kind like they
exactly yes extension of numbers and 412
there are a number of extensions to the
function itself like five new options
and we can have a look at you want in
there yeah okay but what's the default
the default um type here as satellite
right yes in it there are two main
differences with respect to geography
sorry why are we not saying that that's
the default here we should just add in
the documentation that it sees in their
automatic oh yes okay fair enough what
happens I've never even tried some of
these things so if I do sorry we do say
in the main definition box I see it I
see it okay so let's see if I say do I
make sure it's the Pentagon then I
should get pure satellite imagery what
happens if I say um okay why did that do
it at such a big zoom level
I don't think that's right I think we
should try to default depending on the
entity type we should try a more
sensible default yes this making a case
in which we don't have a sighs no II
probably don't have a polygon right I'm
sure but if it's a building and today
it's sure not you know 10 20 miles
across or something so you want geo
image of the Pentagon to be different
from geo image of the Pentagon of
position that's correct
so if you wasn't you for wire arm assume
Level II I like 16 or something like
that
sure I can do that but let's try
something else if I say it's your image
of Lichtenstein how do you spell
Lichtenstein anyway so no wise taking
quite so long by the way do we want to
give some kind of indicator of the fact
that it's downloading stuff we could it
takes a bit longer to connect to digital
globe than to connect to our own files
silver I see I see
and looking at yes so we have satellite
imagery up to soon 11 and from 12
onwards we connect to digital globe okay
and what am I seeing here with outdoor
if I want the outline of Andorra what do
I do it sits in the middle of the
mountains well of the Pyrenees so your
image cannot superimpose a polygon for
that you would have to call Geographics
with a polygon of endure and light with
labels yes you will get some black is
that why is it so small that is
completely crummy yeah that something
went around there it
it may be that that's the highest level
that there is available for the labels
but I have to check that I mean what if
that's the case we should be generating
some okay some message I have to check
that sure but although the resolution of
the is not that great here why is that
why are those things not properly
rendered with proper fonts and so on
well this is the generic discussion of
the resolution both in Geographics and
your image which is whether we give
pixel to pixel results or not and this
effects both geographic sent your image
so in order to be able to control that
there is an now a new option this this
did the right thing that's nice and
crisp right okay so I was asking for a
Geo image which is obviously a bitmap
right whereas this is Geographics is the
nice vector stuff which looks good okay
so let's let's loop back um actually we
have a couple of interesting questions
on the live stream here from Sandro we
have a question will Geographics
understand aspect ratio apparently in
the present situation it just stretches
what right this is the sort of thing we
have been changing recently so try yes
one half or something so yeah that looks
just fine that's exactly what you want
isn't it exactly and and it should work
also in your image we have added these
new a 4-12 good it's also possible to
specify roster size so you can say enjoy
image give me an image of what by the
way that reddened for some reason yes
it's
okay you can also say the roster size
goes to and you say 600 by 300 which
also controls aspect ratio but what
happens if I just give one raster size
did you remove the aspiration and just
never I want to give one raster size
here and I want to see whether it still
respects yeah it does so it raster size
as what the vertical raster sighs I
think it's horizontal one okay I need it
reduces the vertical one and and you can
now also specify separately the image
size so that it does automatically what
you did yeah okay great looks great
okay okay we have another question on
the live stream is the historic geo
image data available do we know the
answer to that image it's like satellite
image you know we don't have that but we
are working on allowing the geoserver
language to specify dates so that we can
connect to national servers yeah so
digital globe not provide that I haven't
seen that they have there's also planet
which is another you know satellite
provider but that we're not hooked up to
so far as I know historical for sure
what are we doing with the Landsat data
which is which is do we have the feed
for Landsat data yet
which is lower resolution but it's daily
yes so so the problem with that is that
they need different protocols of
communications and we are working on
extending our protocol of of
communication the current one we have
doesn't support time or dates but but we
will have that very soon I see so what
do we think so we think that the format
of this will eventually be geo image of
dated Andorra is that right we could
have
that the general language will be in
their server so the Geo server that has
many parameters one of them will be the
date and but of course we can also read
from the input the date and then move
that information to the GS server
well nobody we don't want our users to
have to see anything about the
communication with your server exactly
but sometimes you need a very fine tune
a very fine control of the communication
and then the geoserver language is the
way to go
right but I think that doing a dated of
whatever I'm not sure the day that you
go around and hora I mean you should
probably work but if you have say
Andorra and France with different dates
that's crazy
[Music]
perhaps inside year styling dated of
satellite or lady that second arguments
for the map style or something I search
the same so that so that you're instead
saying something like but I mean it's a
little bit weird when you're saying
dated of automatic yeah we could say
they did off of satellite simply give a
date here
[Music]
let's see someone was Michael Hale is
asking
will there be parity between the
satellite images from Geographics and
geo image which isn't the animating the
golf match and the impression I had was
that geo image had more detailed images
okay so what's the deal with that isn't
it the case that Geographics
with geo styling goes to satellite with
geo styling of satellite is the same as
G of image it's the same the only
difference is that when the assumed is
very high your image automatically
switches to digital globe while your
graphics doesn't but
it's something that we have coated that
way and the reason we did that is
because we don't want people to you know
just suddenly end up getting a big bill
for satellite imagery when they didn't
think they were going to get it exactly
so currently it's still free but at some
point this year it will all right but
but so there's an argument based on in
particular Michaels comments here on the
live stream that we should be if if in
fact Geographics is being asked to do
something which should give you you know
where where you could be getting
high-resolution satellite imagery
arguably we should generate a message
for that case in other words if we ended
up with a situation like this in
Geographics but we should we don't need
to because you just have to tell it yes
please go you ahead and use the proper
satellite imagery right then we should
generate a message for that case in
other words we have subtle imager but
we're choosing not to use it maybe we
should generate a message I sixteen yeah
that's a good idea
you can always say your server goes to
did you know I understand but you have
to tell people that right yeah something
like the message will be something like
by the way we have a bunch of background
noise here um message will be something
like using default low resolution
satellite imagery
use geo Silva
Eero whatever it is DigitalGlobe for
higher resolution babbler for high
resolution stuff right someone on the
livestream is asking can i process
shapefiles I believe the answer to that
I mean as that SHP right as the as the
yes and we have pretty complete import
of those things um to my knowledge and
that's that those will simply they will
flow correctly onto all of this stuff
right what what we returned from an
import of a
of a shape file what is that anyway what
what is the what are the elements that
we return here so it's possible by
default directly it returns a
Geographics output as a junior graphics
or graphics
it used to be graphics and it's now
Geographics okay that by default and but
you can also ask for the individual
elements like like the vector elements
of the input yes and coordinates
projection um right okay okay well that
seems seems good actually we have one
more question on the live stream here if
the resolution is really bad then should
generate a message agreed if the
resolution is okay but could still be
improved will that still generate a
message I think yes I don't see I mean
the question is how annoying this
message is in the case where I mean is
it clear when you have I mean these are
particular zoom levels right we're
supporting the zoom level 11 or
something is that correct it depends on
the layer so for example instead map
will go up to 18 okay for particular
places like Manhattan or something mmm
no I we can always generate it up to 18
but we've cached we've cached it for
places based on density of except of
interesting stuff yeah okay so is it
obvious what is there is there a zone in
which it's kind of acceptable but could
be better versus where it's really
crummy I mean it depends on how many
zoom levels you're off in terms of what
we have available versus what um for
example right now the data in which we
go to less soon is geo elevation data so
when we produce relief maps sometimes
it's very pixelated and so there used to
be a message saying like for this area
we would need some 17 but we can only
give 11 or something like that but
many people complained that by giving
that message alright well so we have to
look at this one I mean by the time it's
as pixelated as that it should be giving
a message the intermediate zone it's not
totally clear right I mean this is okay
let's move on
dynamic Geographics so um somebody is
supporting the idea of cheer image with
respect to time yeah yeah it'll be it'll
be good
particularly with the Landsat data which
is daily right I don't know but but yes
there are there are servers of cloud
covering image measuring which are very
interesting
okay so geodynamic Geographics so we do
not have a dynamic geo image because
basically we don't want to be I mean
that would require many many many tiles
being downloaded all the time so go I
mean beyond zoom level 11 which we
already have on our servers right in
other words we could provide dynamic geo
image to zoom level 11 without any
problems well what would you think
bright so I think these are independent
questions it's a matter the result is
going to look very very similar to
dynamic Geographics because it's just
presenting the tiles the image styles
there well so in other words you're
telling me if I use dynamic Geographics
are you saying how do I get a satellite
image here I was at your background as
to satellite I mean but you could try
even geoserver goes to digital globe
right thanks thank you okay and and how
much is it going to okay let's try this
oh wow okay that's cool so now if I go
in here why isn't that working because
by default that's the highest level we
have of soon Tippett have to go too deep
so it's not switching to digital globe
it sort of maxed out at okay so if I say
juice over here
goes to little globe why doesn't that
autocomplete growl can we make a note
that she ever complain yeah I'll make it
up okay King well no that's cuz it's
complaining about that message from
cloud connects I think is causing the
pinking what was the message well I mean
because you're in 12 and his kid did
something with the public cloud and so
it did the version warning well so this
just works that's pretty neat
so I let's try to walk through the
question of dynamic Geographics why
isn't there a dynamic queue image I said
perhaps it's not to need it
because you just do this exactly it's a
little asymmetric isn't it I mean a
little bit I mean I think we go to some
extent view dynamic dynamic geno image
as sort of maybe not lower-level but its
purpose is to get the background image
for a region yeah I mean its purpose is
to give us something that can be used
for image processing and things like
that rather than something that is going
to be used as a cartography purposes
right um look I think with dynamic
Geographics I'm less comfortable --they
experimental izing that because i think
we don't yet have the family of dynamic
graphics functions and things I think we
should leave that as experimental okay
so I think the cloud support for dynamic
trio graphics they're still not there is
it no I think John has perhaps an intern
who's gonna work on that this summer
cuz I remember correctly okay okay well
so let's leave that as experimental so
Geo image candy experimental eyes
dynamic Geographics today's experimental
got it and we're waiting on dynamic
graphics and cloud support that is
basically correct
and because dynamic graphics I think
it's going to inform how we think about
I mean dynamic graphics are you actively
working on that Brett I mean I haven't
had I haven't changed anything on it
recently so it's not terribly active a
lot of it inherits from Jose's recent
work on geo image and Geographics
because it's calling a lot of the same
internal functionality and whatnot why
did this not work I just tried to do a
copy/paste from dynamic Geographics and
it didn't work
um what did you have copied over well I
I just was selecting the thing which has
an orange border there and I
I didn't copy mmm I wonder if there's I
don't know I mean it's possible there's
something weird with the selection
because it wants to do its own event
paneling so you know sorts of things
okay looks like a bug is that a bug
which is already in 11 3 or is that do
we think that's a new 12 bug I don't
think it's new I'll look into it yeah um
okay
so Connor which I don't completely
understand from the livestream from Ali
Hashmi can you keep capturing images
from a dynamic Geographics as in safe
400 points and then close the stream oh
I switches say like like try to capture
a movie effectively have done out
Geographics I think I wouldn't do it
that way I would do that by doing
Geographics and just recording the just
programmatically generating that
sequence or geo image yes Jo image in
this case right let's see better parity
with dynamic image someone all the live
stream is saying but it does not fit
into purpose of 10 I want clear image so
wait a minute so the question is is died
so that's a good question let's look up
dynamic image and let's see what how
that agrees or doesn't agree with the
design I've done out geo image
Geographics
and the design as I recall is very
different that's not great is it and
this is we just agreed recently to not
be experimental eyes dynamic image so
that so put into your bin of what it
will take to unexperienced i Namek
Geographics there's understanding the
relationship to dynamic image so we've
got it's dynamic graphics dynamic
Geographics dynamic image yeah i think
that they're a little bit different use
cases but we should I think we can focus
on that separately there's one of things
that you want to do here is that you
have you want to measure things you know
but you might want to do that in
Geographics too yes you absolutely what
is what is the measurement here what do
you mean by measure things here let's
see I mean this is also a file back to
creature whereas you know dynamic
Geographics is a virtual file back
creature backed by data from a server
right um someone our live stream is
saying that that copy/paste works fine
11:3 so it's just some bug in 12 okay um
okay
are we um do we think we're done with
the discussions for Geographics right
now yes okay let's take a look
next item so those who are here for the
Geographics business can leave and the
next item is persistence functions okay
okay okay Roman yes I mean they have
these two value P processing function
and merging function which have what is
what is experimental still with the
persistent stuff I mean this is all the
persistent value mechanism right yes I
mean we have I think there are two two
areas one is persistence and the other
is initialization and I'm fairly
confident of doing the persistence
persistent very persistent object making
them no longer experimental but I've
like to keep the initialization stuff as
experimental because we are not finished
yet with how to initialize the kernel
and initialize cloud kernels and stuff
like that okay so persistent value just
to review here what we're saying is
these are values that can be made
persistent across different kinds of
persistence locations and the
persistence locations are being
specified in the second argument I this
is not wonderful that it doesn't give
okay so the persistence locations
include kernel sessions front-end
sessions cloud okay so where's the there
are additional things to come here right
in the in the persistence locations yes
I mean that's the that's the cookie and
server based things for cloud API calls
and stuff like that but for this session
is that correct web session is another
one that's the name that we're giving to
the additional if I'm not mistaken
that's the name being given to the if
you open that thing persist location in
D in the source form then you will see
all of that stuff so this list
what list well what is that you know
that's just a comment about because this
this is used for generating auto
completion so that's about what this
comment comment about documentation
tagging I mean if if we're going to how
is that being picked up by the
autocomplete er requires a manual a
one-time selection of this list and
adding it to the autocomplete stuff
where is the autocomplete stuff is that
in this documentation source file
somewhere in the indian nodes or in the
hidden stuff of this notebook I mean you
know standard I don't understand how it
works but I've been told to do it this
way and so whenever there is a change
you have to do something to descendant
due to it I mean they said there's a
button in the in the toko tools to
extract that information somehow oh
they're Gables sir Tomatoes Roger
anybody else here know that they stay it
says their notes tables insert argument
date so they sat there supposed to be a
notes table somewhere in the local tools
yeah I understand where xored inserting
that later into some hidden stuff inside
this notebook that's what we said okay
this is Roger still here in this Roger
know the answer I'm here but I don't
know the answer to that we hadn't seen
any problems with this isn't really come
up okay
that's we could get um who's I don't
know listen don't we we don't have
anybody from project management here do
we
maybe um it would be good to get an
answer how that actually works maybe
Brian could somebody could contact Brian
and ask him to let us know okay
um okay okay so this is the additional
things cookie managed oh that will be
manual stand server session these are
the two new ones that I'm working on
which are for cloud only for API calls
and stuff like that and for cloud
sessions okay and yes okay and do you
think that they will come to closure in
the same way the other ones have or are
they going to require additional options
and things they don't require additional
options but they really need support
code in the cloud so they are more tied
to cloud release versions tend to
release versions and do you have any
idea when when the cloud folks are going
to support those things well I mean it
at the moment it depends on me because I
need to taste most of the support code
should be ready and as soon as I get
around to continue working on the cloud
stuff then I will be able to tell you
exactly how much work there is but at
the moment I don't have something it's
not making it under 147 for example
instead the next released version no 146
is the one for this week one for it
smoke a couple of weeks from now no no
that that would be after that time okay
all right okay all right let's take a
look at these I I'm a little bit
reluctant here to to them I feel like
this whole system has not been as
adequately banged on as we might like
the whole persistent values yeah I mean
there are several areas I mean the
persistent value persistent yes who uses
it today and for what I mean it has some
internal use for caching certain things
and it's used for once isn't it yes I
mean that's
that's one use and it's used and it's
used in the kernel initialization but
that part is not it's not stable enough
but what's the point there is to
preserve things across sessions right so
yes so in principle I mean I don't think
that we you know in various development
teams I don't think we've been
particularly aware of this functionality
I agree it has not been well advertised
yes I mean one thing I intend to do and
I hope to do so for the European
developer conference coming up in June
is to give an example of how to use this
for storing preferences for a package of
application yes because I don't know and
probably a workflow that particular is
you yes I mean it's it's more than a
single workflow I mean it's it's not
that trivial but certainly it will be a
couple of workflows because at the
moment I think we don't have a standard
way of supporting preferences even our
own preferences are I mean the front end
stores them somewhere but yes well those
should be look we should standardize
that stuff I mean in other words because
we've got preferences now in for example
between cloud and desktop there's no
reason you can't share a bunch of
preferences like that's right opens if
you change your nickname or something in
the cloud I think it does change in the
desktop but how that works I don't know
mm-hmm
do you know no I don't I mean the the
way this works is that I mean if we use
these persistent things for storing
preferences then the switch between
cloud desktop or even merging and
looking up different places will be will
be straightforward no I understand
all right listen I don't think we should
be experimental eyes this stuff I'm not
quite ready I think we should try and
finish the whole system yeah I mean
that's fine I mean then then we can just
say that the whole thing will stay
experimental and we'll gather more use
cases and also advertise this more
internet I think so but it wouldn't hurt
to try to use it for some real yes yes I
agree
11
confidence will go way up okay so I
think that's that's it for that and
somebody has got a loose connection on
their audio um let's move to the next
and much bigger topic of system malwa
okay then I'll leave here thank you
bye thanks see Roman the UM okay what is
the state okay so what the heck is this
what was this this link doesn't I don't
even understand what these links are
free argh - guide pages and I don't
think the British system I am Raj this
was sorry about that
I guess I didn't fix the links or the
guide pages but those are the guide
pages okay
but okay oh okay talking about this
stuff in general well let's go look
let's go to sur guide page what's the
main guide page here um presumably it's
under engineering where is it systems
modeling right okay so this whole
business where are we at with with
turning this into a repository system
this okay so that's that work is
progressing but we're that's not gonna
happen 412 it's not on that timeline but
not too far ahead you know behind that
but it's not but just to be clear what
where we're going with that I think that
you know um we were not advocating de
experimental izing this anyway because
we wanted to wait out that and you need
to be educated about galleries and other
things I agree we didn't have our silent
meeting about I did not and I think that
that can you know that can be a bigot
you know if we developed that well I
think that will do a great service to us
in for people exploring all the data
that we have the built in knowledge so I
agree so I mean just just to clarify
what we're talking about there I mean
right now we have the only way that you
can browse the data repository is on the
web
we don't have an in in product in
notebook browsing capability we only
have searching capability the repository
and what you're proposing a general
browsing capability for literature
basically well that end but else a bill
T data like polyhedra and data could
provide gallery views and pick from
there you know there's a ton of we have
a ton of that provide probably I'm sorry
about that it provide can provide just
much easier way to explore and
understand and use our data
but so I agree so like element data
could do the same thing exactly um but
so what what's the I mean this the
it doesn't suit so they're two different
things going on I think that this mode
of finding things when we search things
you know on web and not our repositories
we're gonna build a similar thing for
we're building a similar thing for audio
now what's the audio thing it's gonna be
a repository of audio stuff now we are
we are calling into existing repository
so for instance SoundCloud for music and
free sound for sound effects and those
kinds of things but just to understand
their um the what you're saying is I
mean within the data repository for
example there is an audio section of the
data repository isn't there there is
yeah but it's tiny you know I mean we
aren't we added but it's it's still it
there's no comparison with the millions
of you know pieces that are available
right but but so one of the things that
we have here is something where we've
got a canonical name like if I go to
audio here sure yeah the audio cats and
dogs
whatever um okay so that's a random what
is that that's random meows and and
whoops and things that might be a recent
thing that we added because you know we
have audio identify yes there's some
coming up with character encoding Raj
that's for you I think it's subversion
12 bug of some kind okay so this is I
don't have my computer set okay so that
what Noth is that what is that that's
the expanded interface I see okay so
then I can say for example um that sub 3
comma one probably and that's that thing
and so I could say spectrogram and I
would get the cat spectrogram is that
right for instance you that really what
the heck does that sound like is that a
pillar or something well you were
listening to it I'm not listening to it
because I don't have my um I just
changed some things here so I let me
just see okay I'm just I don't think I
can play this through the computer in an
easy way here um all right let me just
find out what this says actually I'm
using that you can play it so everybody
can hear it to listen into this thing to
how you set that up
device hmm that's one of the devices
that you can add
tell me how to do that zum-zum is a
device okay but sir wait a minute how do
I actually do it so if I say is there a
dollar audio devices I mean yeah yeah
exactly
what are your output devices yes okay
zoom audio device is that right yeah
okay so what do I do I say dollar what
do I do here
well better said it's a dollar you know
dollar okay then what do I set hold on
no no think you have to you have to hold
on okay this isn't highly relevant but I
am really curious what what sound it is
that looks like that I don't know it
doesn't oh is it a meow I don't know um
or is it neither okay well let me know
if you figure that out but okay but the
basic point here I'm sorry for the audio
repository you're saying that you want
to have so Roger
are you aware no not for the audio pasti
so the thing is that the you know a
search function to search you know for
you know a whole slew of audio
repositories in the world I understand
so one thing might be relevant to you
there is this concept of external
identifier which is what we're using
this is an Alan Joyce in me production
it's a thing for taking the canonical
identifies from things like Wikipedia
and wicked data or protein databank or
whatever else any place that has a
canonical external identifier and being
able to map that onto being able to
reference things by their external
identifiers that's great and there are a
bunch of those across you know every
repository had them one way or another
no no I understand that but the point is
to have a mechanism a uniform mechanism
for us to refer to external repository
identifier so to speak so that I think
might be relevant to what you're talking
about with getting data from sound
cloud and things like this right um okay
but let's return here
so anyways back to the system all our
examples we were not ready to CD
experimental eyes that yet because I
think that these two other stages that
needs to pass okay but what you are
saying is that something like system
model so that's what this turns into
right is that thing is a system model
correct yes and that if I plus it here
you need to load of functionality by
using one of the symbols not good enough
come on
you surely should be able to capture the
event and deal with that I'll look into
that okay so if I just type the word
system model is it going to do it yes by
the way whatever that was is that head
small bug yes that's a fixed this
morning book okay by the way I assume
you're gonna standardize on the the the
monitoring you know the loading
indicators whenever that gets actually
standardized who is dealing with that I
haven't heard anything from those of
that meeting that was we had a couple
meetings about that standardization that
I didn't hear any more about it does
somebody know whose size specialize for
a product managing it's okay hey Eric
could you check in with Sushma and find
out what's happening with that yes
thanks for everything
okay so then this your system model plot
then just work some loops whatever
happens here system or a lot of that
thing
Shh
do you have the concert okay so that's
again a non-standardized right
okay um by the way are you considering
some kind of attached cell mechanism for
actions associated with these system
models or is that not yes yes eventually
okay for yet okay so let's take a look
at what you're proposing here so you're
proposing to do experimental eyes system
model and system model plot and so on is
that correct yes most of the functions
not all of them so what do we think the
still the the kind of problematic areas
are here I mean they're a little bit
different cases but if we go through
them linearly oh you mean in this
function itself yeah and this function
for instance so what's the level of
experience that people have had in using
this I mean it's the underlying stuff
has been and has been used externally by
customers for many years now well right
so the underlying code base is pretty
stable and most of the we didn't do huge
design changes for before putting it
into or from language proper so most of
this stuff is actually well tested and
has stood the test of time except in the
cases where it didn't where we changed
it for this situation so I think the
design we currently have is is very good
and more importantly extendable in many
places in the places we want it we want
to add stuff in the future okay so for
example if I would say here I might see
one of the properties by the way there's
no water complete here there should be
autocomplete here yes it's also on my
lists I
understand this this is some horrifying
thing um it's the underlying code
basically uh there isn't one like a
display which gives you a highlighter
what is the symbolic version what is our
symbolic version of this we we don't
have one
yeah that's it yeah it's a huge future
project this is c plus plus sized yeah
so fair enough
I mean and we don't particularly care
because people are making these things
using our graphical tools and system
model uh primarily yes so that's kind of
a low-level again one day but I don't
see it I mean it's there are use cases
but they're not strong just yeah by the
way this reminds me I mean there's some
kind of weird for hunting issue that I
think that you could use cases for
having a complete symbolic
representations are strong but not in
comparison to a big effort it would take
to actually do it what's that how do I
get the variables associated with the
system is allowed system variables I
think wow
taking time here why did that take time
because it has to go from the compiled
if hierarchical structure to actually
resolve everything it's basically a
compilation step so this thing here what
the heck is this
it's a quantity variable and why is the
uniform taking forever okay so those are
quantity variables which are unitless
quantity variables is that correct in
this case they are a unitless if there
would have been unit information on the
other side in the model they would not
be unitless okay so if I would say
system model plot of
this thing actually that thing comma and
then a list I don't know what the heck
I'm doing here but I'm just gonna put
some of these in right right you might
have got internal variables there yeah
so the flattened version where you query
for the variables can contain internal
variables that he needs this of the
equations but are not present in the end
result of a simulation so if you would
look like the first three or some some
of the aquaria Buhl's that did not
contain the ler there then it that would
it worked okay so hold on so the
convention is that our things are
intermediate variables inside the system
is that correct yes yes that is correct
um um okay
so I don't quite understand so system
variables how am I you know properties
related to the whole model are where do
I see system variables here if you
scroll down there properties related to
equations and variables okay
so system
variable so I don't understand what this
means that this is not making it very
clear so output variables is that the
things I want for purposes of those are
the things that are relevant there's
only one right okay what about internal
variables that I can see that are still
being solved for everything that does
not contain the dollar thing so if you
yeah so you can either go back to the
system variables or you can if you do
the system model simulate explicitly on
your model first and you get a result
which you can query for the actual
solved variables I don't quite
understand that why do I need to what
why isn't that something where it knows
what will be the solved variables here
I'm asking yes seems like you should be
able to do that yeah okay what's going
on there why is that not working those
are not dollar variables yeah that
trigger worked it surprised me okay all
right but so fundamentally what should
be happening here but why is that named
camel there that filter with different
differentiation why's that camel do it
isn't there a non camel the original the
model was camel I see okay
um okay all right so give me a sense
then so right now the only way so you
have this way of browsing models here
that is but what is that one I'm so
that's I mean that's good let's do
that's a it's not a good way to browse
it just gives you the typesetting of
that thing takes a while
yeah that's why are we not cashing those
we are so why does it take so long
because there's tons of dynamic I mean
every typeset thing is a dynamic because
of the expand collapse thing but I don't
understand why the caching doesn't give
you I'm very confused by my caching
doesn't make this much faster the
caching is on the level of the rendered
stuff what I mean with that is the image
not I mean in the end you need to the
front-end needs to render 400 something
boxes with dynamic module and images in
them this was not very good you did you
talk to the front-end team about
speeding this up no not yet okay because
this oh I see I didn't see that there
were 411 missing things here yeah well
hmm I think he needs to talk about how
to speed this up and I don't know
whether there's a way of giving an
initialization for the now module which
gives you a cache or something I'm not
sure how that should work but clearly
what I'm doing right now is definitely
not working it's kind of frozen my front
end here right I'll add it to my list um
okay so in terms of usage in in
language usage of this amino we you know
these are just very very complicated
designs and I understand that they're
well tested in the external system
modeler environment and much of this is
well tested by external customers what's
that the in language design is also well
tested by many customers we know that we
have many external customers using this
right but they using they were using it
in the previous former was not a
built-in feature of the language what
did we change when we made it a built-in
feature of the language what what kinds
of things did we change here well well
all the names but but there was a lot of
streamlining that we could do since we
had experience with it yes okay I don't
really like the phrasing of that I we I
hate using these things mean that that
what does this you mean now you're deep
into how in a model you can store
information about what what system model
plot should plot by default that's what
and there's basically an association
format for this position okay look
I'm not quite sure how to do this review
because there's a pretty big area and
what is the you know we're still seeing
some things here what is this now why is
this and again why is this so damn slow
because it has to render the diagram
from the original model because it that
the expanded form is not cached okay so
look this is clearly not a you know a
happy you know the fact that this is
taking so long it's not a happy thing
yeah and in this case the reason it's
take take took so long to render is
probably because there's tons of you
have gradients in there which are
expensive because they use textures okay
so and by the way if I would have set
one of these things up on an API for
example where I want kind of is that
even vaguely possible or am I going to
end up with every single API call it's
going to burn all this time setting
everything up is in other words is there
some version of this where I can take
some output simulated thing that will
then be blindingly fast to run yes there
is such a thing and that's one of the
things we want to do when we get close
in the process of getting cloud support
is to have examples pre-compiled so like
by the way why is that star there that
tells me that you're faking this in
other words that's not the unit system
that put that star there is it I'm not
so sure
really well I mean if I say I did look
like I was making stuff there okay well
let's look to newton-meters right
presumably right
that looks really weird that looks wrong
from a different point of view yeah that
looks very wrong to another point of
view um Wow okay I'm surprised we do
that I bet that's a case that's never
really come up okay but but so if I were
to plot so let's say I make a table of
quantity
you know let's say random real Newton
meters
20 why is this too
forever okay it's a little weird but
that's okay so let's say let's plot that
okay what enough happened here that
should have worked right I would have
expected it that this shows something
and why didn't quantity oh no you had
the second array to you the second
argument to your quantity is actually a
quantity value not the quantity unit I
know but that should resolve right
quantity should should ingest it the
quantity object like that correctly I
have never used it that way it's
possible it's supposed to I believe I
mean again ROG maybe you can that would
Molly be for Jose and so on I think we
probably have the wrong people to
discuss this particular thing here but
let's see what happens if we say um yeah
I don't think we can do this I mean this
is a really grotesque way to do it which
I don't think it's going to work very
well but let's try that I mean that this
is something that works but shouldn't
work okay where are the
I know I don't think it plot shows you
and it's by default but it can do it yes
you say axis label automatic what on
earth is it doing there
oh I see what earth did it do that look
at look at that case look what it just
did
that's a nasty bug ROG that's for you I
mean the whole Orion version 12 issue
right I'll look into that
okay something is wrong here
somebody is okay first of all that MN
thing is wrong and that's another thing
we should take to Michael I guess okay
umm yes someone on the livestream is
running out that newton-meters is Jules
I know the the second thing is you're
faking something here I'm looking into
it okay um so and the third thing so
let's take this as an example it's a
slightly more complicated example line
28 and let's see if I can figure out so
you're saying if I say output variables
here those are the things that I can
plot is that correct what can i pluck
more than just output variables you said
I can't more okay why is
so slow I just don't get it what is it
doing well that's even more bizarre yeah
that is bizarre because that would just
work didn't it it was it's a different
model oh it's a different model might be
a bug wait a moment
it's there right yeah yeah but you used
how do you validate these models is
there some testing procedure for each
model to check that that's what it's
supposed to have we have a ton so tests
and unfortunately some of the models are
failing okay but so I mean that's a pure
QA so we waive it but these models come
from that Metallica standard library oh
these are what's the story here this one
comes from the Metallica standard
library some of them come from our own
example.i briefs okay but so let's say
it's from a Metallica standard library
and it fails our test would we do that
depends how badly it fails if it fails
really badly we remove them in our
version and how many have that has that
happened to only roughly a few a handful
okay but so in a case like this what
would you expect so I mean if I say here
if I'm giving this model and I said why
is it even taking wow it's even slow to
paste something needs to be you need to
talk to the front-end team see what we
can do here because I mean look it's not
even typing properly here right I
experience that's all well it may not be
helped by going through screen sharing
all that kind of stuff
right after out that the variables
doesn't work that's not gonna work
either
okay okay so and so these kinds of
things like system variables and so on
if you have an attached cell I actually
do you don't even have an auto you don't
even have an auto suggestion cell do you
what does what does the suggestions bar
do underneath one of these things we
don't have that yet okay but so when you
have an attached cell that will allow
you to ask for things like variables and
so on correct yes but it's an iterative
process to make that really useful in
attached cell it takes it takes many
rounds to get it very useful no I agree
what's the state of getting this stuff
to run on the cloud we're working on it
but it's it's a hard problem because
right now a lot of sandbox happening on
our end the system model or kernel so I
mean I'm sorry you're saying you're
installing sandboxing there or what yes
yes okay and yeah we basically have to
install some boxing protections in every
single part of our infrastructure our
countless containerize the whole thing
somehow apparently that's not doable at
least because I mean what you're doing
is you're generating R or C code to run
correct raw C++ code yes okay I mean
that's only one of the possible security
problems what's an example of another
one you can restore it you can save
models and wherever you want them and
you in the cloud you obviously only are
allowed to store save models in some
places for example I see
and the system on the colonel has a
large list of interactive functions that
this functionality calls and some of
them we have to block and cloud and some
of them we have to block partially in
cloud right look I you know this is yeah
we're fairly host here I don't know what
it's doing any idea what it's doing or
how to stop it or it's not even giving
the dynamic content warning just try
stopping it without period I did it's
not happy okay look let's I mean I have
to say I I don't see the harm in leaving
this stuff is experimental for another
restoration I mean do you I mean it
seems it feels like there's still some
some shakedown to go through here oh I
don't mind that either yeah I mean I
think the design is good but you know we
do have some problems like the ones you
discover here so let's just talk about
validating the design because what we
really need to make sure of is that this
stuff can be in pipelines with other
things and what do we expect those
things to be I mean in other words it
should be routinely the case that people
can use
you know mechanical devices as I mean
okay like let me give an example okay
let's say you have a model for an
appliance like a washing machine or
something okay tell me if this is
realistic can I run the model to predict
the audio output from washing machine
it's that realistic I mean it
realistic if you build your model to
have that much detail in that direction
I mean you can have a hundred different
models of washing machines that model
different aspects of the washing machine
right right right but assuming we've got
some vibration data coming out how would
we take that from here and turn it into
an audio some kind of if you do system
model simulate of your washing machine
you get the system model simulation data
which has an accessor for which outputs
audio directly what do you mean it
outputs audio directly it gives you an
audio object for the for the variable e
requests how how do i but this is really
upsetting what's doing here I'm gonna
have to kill this this system yeah growl
just kill the colonel
don't force quit the whole you know use
the front in to kill the current I have
to reenter the front is not responding
anymore Oh somebody's asking does
Activity Monitor assistant process stage
the problem is we can't get to system
process data and actually the colonel
were not that colonel task our colonel
tasks whichever one it is this one here
maybe do I really want to do that it
says will
Desktop is not responding I don't think
killing the colonel TAS couldn't be
enough no I don't think so either
usually when the front end stops
responding this hard it's kill
everything okay not not great do you
have any sense of why that happened here
I would guess some interaction between
the dynamic stuff and that there is a
ton of bitmap textures in that image so
it's a heavy image okay so it sounds to
me like you have some work to do with
the front end team to try to understand
how to optimize that stuff yes okay so
back to this for a minute um we were
just talking about you were telling me
that system models simulate has a
mechanism for giving audio output which
is entertaining is it specifically audio
output I mean hi okay I want to hedge my
my statement by I'm not sure if we
documented that particular form yet but
I hope so we have the implementation at
least so if you go this is the model
simulation data well so system models
simulate right
gives us a model simulation data yes and
and the reason it does that is because
you get usually a ton of you know you
can have a thousand you know functions
coming out of it right then it also has
my not data about the simulation which
you want to keep so if I say this for
example system model simulates of that
simple circuit well it's a problem of
some kind yeah I fix this morning
it's what influence you I don't good ok
so now I've got the simulation data now
what do I do to explore it it has
properties ok
and you know really there should be some
kind of this this suggestions do you
know how to work with that framework or
not I been in contact with I think it's
a yes I've been in contact with Jose
okay so what is this showing me here
these are all the properties of the this
is basically all the metadata you have
about the information about the
simulation okay so how do I get so if I
wanted to take percent one of a specific
time like six point seven for example
and then you need to specify what
variable you want that's expensive why
this is a complicated business okay so
this is what is variable so it will be
state variables or what variable names
or parameter names the variable names
are the interesting ones
oh boy so then what do I want to do I
want to say but I just want this is a
function of time I want to get the value
of a particular variable as a function
of time how do I do yes don't you do
percent one bracket variable the
variable name you want kamati okay so
resistor to dot V for example and that's
a quantity variable actually in this
case it's a string why why is it a
string in some cases in a quantity
variable in others I'm not sure we
always have the quantity information at
this stage but I guess we could have it
I think we need to decide what we're
doing that right
yeah it's that's nice that's cool yes
that's what originally Stephen did
because when we get interpolating
functions we get exactly the same
workflows from other ways of solving
differential equations that's nice okay
so wait a minute so you're saying if I
were to say here if I were to just say
percent one of resistor to dot V oh yeah
then you get interpolating function so
that is okay so
thing is returning functions this thing
when given the name of variable returns
a function representing the results as a
function of always of time because time
is the only I mean we don't have PDE
like they know but no no this is this is
this is time this is or their ordinary
or differential algebraic equations so
light bulb over time right um okay well
we still got a lot more to talk about
with these I just don't know quite how
to organize the discussion about the
stuff I mean it seems like you guys are
progressing well with this is there do
you want is that stuff we should be
talking about or is it just chugging
along
I think it's chugging along and there
are there whole points of synchronizing
with outer things we talked about
galleries we talked about repositories
to talk about completions we talked
about other things that we didn't yet
talk about which is major uptick to some
of the analysis functionality like
linearization and other things fair
enough and we're cloud in progress there
many things in progress um okay I think
we're out of time for this meeting
actually for those who are on the
livestream we're about to jump to
another meeting which will also be
live-streamed but we'll start a
different stream for that um someone had
asked about actually the two questions
from a live stream here somebody had
asked about they hoped we were gonna get
too near on that sorry not today
actually the people involved in this are
several of them uh traveling right now
this is a this is going to be a long and
painful discussion this is about whether
our whole neuron that layer framework is
ready to commit to for forever um and
I'm quite unsure about that second there
was a comment on the live stream about
the Newton meters problem um I think the
answer to that is how another we're
gonna solve it the answer is it's really
a print form issue it's not so much a an
issue of um
it's not so much an issue of actually
putting those units in the right order
it's a question of how do we print out
that we print out em n which is look
looks like milling Newtons
or do we print out an M and I have no
idea what that sorting criterion is I'm
sure Michael knows what the sorting
criterion is but something has goofed up
in in that regard I'm pretty sure off
now four would sort that correctly so
there's some some issue there um all
right well thanks already in this
meeting thanks on the live stream those
on the live stream I strongly encourage
you to come join our next live stream
which will be starting momentarily um
all right talk to y'all soon